demi lovato hints at a relapse in her
new song ariana is bringing the light as
her whirlwind romance continues
happy Friday friends we made it
weekend is upon us and with that some
new music Friday tracks I'm gonna kick
things off today with Demi Lovato
surprised confession now et has learned
Demi has relapse after six years of
sobriety and she's expressing her
struggles in her new song sober daddy
please forgive me for the drink spilled
on the floor so never left me we've been
down this road before I'm so sad
alcohol we're told that's the source of
Demi's downfall and one of her demons
the source tells ET the relapse happened
at some point between April and May
while she was on tour well she put it
all out there on this new track and
another source tells ET quote her song
is intense but that's how she deals she
has to be brutally honest and put it out
there so that she's not burdened with
holding on to her struggles privately
and you know what we got to give props
to Demi for being so honest about all of
her struggles sorry not sorry if I would
have continued down that road it would
have been I don't know if I'd be here
today so it's something that's very
important to me and then I've been able
to share my story with other people and
I've had fans that come up to me and
tell me you know because you got sober I
got sober
Demi keeps it real and apparently also
accountable so that's inspiring shine on
girl alright another young pop diva who
is shining bright herself miss Ariana
Grande she's had a major couple weeks
and drop a new video for her latest
single the light is coming tea tree
Nicki Minaj a high five
[Music]
hey that's a little bit of a Bop
all right this track is off her upcoming
album sweetener and can you tell it was
produced by Pharrell it's definitely
giving me some any Rd vibes
I'm also the video for Nicki and Ari's
other clap bet is dropping any day now
Nikki's been teasing it and it looks
good well the new music of course comes
just after we learned Ariana and Pete
Davidson are engaged after just one
month of dating listen we've been saying
it a lot with these two but when you
know you know except if you saw Pete on
The Tonight Show this week his first
interview since the engagement well you
could tell you that he was shocked you
feel like I want a contest how are you
how you handling it all right now it has
been really Lynn hey you guys could of
course can catch up on all things REM
Pete on et online.com slash daily daddy
but we've got to move on to a couple
other tracks including this beautiful
acoustic ditty from our favorite crooner
Sam Smith check out this video which the
soul singer shot in Verona anything to
town you out tonight
baby
Oh
[Music]
haha
don't think about tomorrow
servus myth you make me crazy okay I
love him
but something tells me that one was for
Sam's boyfriend thirteen recent star
Brandon Flynn but that's okay
everything's fine everything's fine all
right and finally I couldn't leave you
guys without a banker this week enjoy
this bought from rudimental and Major
Lazer called let me live
[Music]
and finally shout out to see Vincent who
just dropped this sexy and sweaty video
for her Club hit die slow disco
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you go I hope this kick starts
your weekend right and we'll be back on
Monday with another dose of daily Deni
so make sure you're subscribed to e
t--'s youtube channel and i'll see you
guys back here then right